Mahlzeit grüß Dich ich bin der Jochen he
blink doch du arschl hier aus berghheim
und Umgebung also schön hier Berkheim
bnen
Race herrlich das ist Heimat das ist
Natur einfach
schön ich genieße meine
Freiheit Taxifahrer macht 18,70 € ne ja
hier nee komm B
[Musik]
gefährliches
halbwis der Jahresrückblick
2023 mit Jochen also da bin
ich ach hallo tagchenön junge
Frau kommen Sie rein können Sie
rausgucken froh neues frohes Neues aber
hallo
2023 leck mich am
[Musik]
Arsch andere Musik machen sind aber
Pingel hab
was Radio Mallorca Meeresrauschen hör
mal gut war nicht alles schlecht gewesen
hier Januar z.B der L los waren hier der
Verteidigungsministerin so ne ja da habe
ich schon ein flächekt aufgemacht gut
nicht während der Arbeitszeit sondern
wen der Mittagspause die landbrech als
Verteidigungsministerin die ist ungefähr
so überflüssig wie eine Sonnenbank in
der Wüste ja also nicht falsch verstehen
ich liebe Frauen viele meine besten
Freundinnen sind auch Frauen so aber die
sind alle kompetent also am
Herd ja Mäuschen mit den mit den anderen
Frauen das war ja nicht so gemeint lass
mich do mal Ausreden ich Ken ja gar
keine Frauen außer die jetzt hier
einsteigen und hallo
Mäuschen Bo die alte hat war Funkloch
ach so ne alte meinte ich jetzt
hallo ganz ehrlich ich sehe ja auch
scheiße aus in tfleg aber deshalb werde
ich auch nicht Verteidigungsminister ich
sag ja immer wieder augen auf bei der
Berufswahl ja aber ich weiß noch ganz
genau wie ich das Internet aufgemacht
habe und da sehe ich der Lamprecht da
stehen in Afrika in schön mit Hosenanzug
und luftigen stöckelchuhen und die Haare
waren aufriert ich habe zuerst gedacht
das W Werbung gewesen perfekter Halt die
frisuritz drei wettertaft ich habe auch
genau das gleiche gedacht was ich den
Soldaten im Gesicht angesehen habe leck
mich am Arsch das kann heiter werden
also in dem Wort heiter steckt auch
Eiter ich meine muss mal vorstellen du
bist sater in Afrika das ist ja auch sau
gefährlich jetzt nicht nur wegen dem
Krieg da sondern auch wegen ganzen Tiere
der mit Skorpion da reicht ein so ein
kleiner P da liegst direkt in der Kiste
nach Hause dann steht da die alte so als
als wä eine kommunionsumzug da gewesen
so du wirst von der Wanderdüne überholt
e ja gut das Silvester Video von der
lprech das war dagegen der Knaller da
fand ich sch nicht schlecht der Effekte
waren doch besser als bei jeden Marvel
Filmen b b b außerdem endlich mal jemand
der neue arbeitet und mir das Auto voll
kurz sieht doch
aus und auch am 20 spieltag der
Bundesliga Bundesliga da spielen Firmen
gegen Firmen die sind alle geschmiert in
Finnland Finnland was interessiert mich
ob in Finnland unser Kreis die
kernkraftwerkeland is und auf weiß
wissen Sie eigentlich was ich letztes
Jahr an Strom bezahlt habe 43 Cent das
ist ja fast normal das heißt also mit
anderen Worten wenn ich Maline Badewanne
einlaufen lasse dann sind das mal locker
6 € also deswegen sie müssen schon
entschuldigen aber irgendwo muss man ja
sparen so ne aber da schalte ich doch
nicht die drei Kernkraftwerke ab ja gut
aber die sind halt auch schon gefährlich
ne ich weiß dieses chanilder oder dieses
fokohila Chima ja die Chinesen die
Chinesen die machen doch eh was zu
wollen aber wir haben doch Inflation
Krieg Fußball läuft auch scheiße da
schmeiß ich doch nicht drei gut
geschmierte Kernkraftwerke Weg zack neue
Brennstäbe rein dann flumt das doch
wieder das ist genauso wie mein altes
Nokia ist ein Dingen da da können sie
den Nägel mit in der Wand hauen da nicht
letztens Wand mit reingerissen ich habe
ein Umzug gemacht mit dem Klaus ja und
wir haben die Waschmaschine von ihm
damit
angekeilt ja und ja ja der radioaktive
Abfall ist ja so gefährlich und niemand
will das Lagern ja natürlich nicht
passen Sie auf der Trick ist nicht alles
an eine Stelle verbuddelt ich habe bei
meiner Ex-Frau ja da habe ich das P
saniert hat ich ja versprochen da habe
ich die Fliesen ab hieren den
giipskarton ab in die graue Tonne der
Trick ist paar alte Spaghetti drauf von
der Nachbarn vielleicht ein paar
beschissene Windeln drauf fertig ist der
L so muss man sich n ein bisschen Zeit
lassen von wegen 90 € bauabfall hier
beim Entsorger ja nichts außerdem ist
das ja eh alles Natur ne das kommt von
der Erde geht in der Erde dann rechts
aben auf bahnstra rechts ich denk linkss
ja ich fah jetzt aber links ja und der
Sommer war auch scheiße gewesen ich sag
nur PKW Maut Schadensersatz vi
Milliarde 250 Millionen dass wir die BKW
Maut nicht haben das war der teuerste
nichts des Jahres und wer darf das alles
zahlen wir also was Sie machen müssen
Sie wissen ich zahl ja nichts ohne mich
mein Vorschlag der anticheuermaut jedes
Mal wenn der Otto vor die Tür geht in
Deutschland zack 100 € weg und der
Vignette muss er sich auf die Stirn
kleben und die ist dann auch immer nur
für eine Stunde gültig und die stinkt
nach Fisch ja also nicht falsch
verstehen ja wenn andere Leute einfach
hier hinkommen und unsere schöne
Autobahn kaputt fahren dann dürfen die
dafür auch gefällig Blechen ist doch so
ne das war ja eigentlich auch eine gute
Idee gewesen aber dann verkack ich das
ganze doch nicht da musst du doch zu EU
gehen und sagen hör mal Leute hier
Franzosen schütter hier eure scheiß
autob muss auch jedes Mal bezahlen oder
nee oder dieses heizungsgesetz das ist
da auch ein Katastrophe ja der schöne
geföhnte habbeck ich wohne ja im Haus
meiner Eltern also jetzt nicht bei
meinen Eltern sondern bei meinen Eltern
so rein technisch gesehen geh das Haus
eigentlich mir also noch nicht aber wenn
die W die H das dauert auch nichtmer
lang dann dann ist das formsche und die
Heizung die hat der Vater gerade erst
erneuert hat war die ist ja praktisch
neu hier
1992 ja und jetzt kommt der schön
geföhnte habck daher und sagt mir hey
reichsverschluss ausrasten Taxen haben
immer vorfacht haben immer
vorfacht ja ist so ist so so keine uber
uber haben niemals Vorfahrt sie fahren
doch keine uber sonst
oder dann ist ja gut sonst wä der
Bahnhof nä mich jetzt hier direkt an der
Ecke ja auf jeden Fall das geht so nicht
mit dem heizungsgesetz ja gut hat mit
dem
klimmerwandel ich sag ja nicht dass ich
da nichts ändern muss ne aber ich meine
viel Jute hat es ja auch so macht der
Sommerschlussverkauf eigentlich Sinn
weil du am Ende des Sommers die
Sommerklamotten kaufst und sie dann
direkt anziehen kannst im Oktober ist ja
nicht schlecht ne aber vieles von dem
ganzen Scheiß da macht ja überhaupt
keinen Sinn B du z. Beispiel ja ich denk
es wird immer heißer werden aber die
Wohnung da werde ich dazu gezwungen die
jetzt zu isolieren zu ten ja das ist
doch schwachsin die haben doch zu viel
Steinwolle geschnüffelt wo Küst du denn
eigentlich her aus Bayern
Bayern eiwanger hier der Söder erst ja
das müssen wir natürlich jetzt erstmal
klärin also das so geht's ja gar nicht
und dann ja so schlimm war doch nicht
war Jugendsünde machen wir das jetzt
demnächst immer so wenn man eine jwal
gewinnen wollen oder so sind salabim Hex
Hex ja so ist das mit dem richtigen
Parteibuch da hast du später mal
ausgesorgt wenn du kriminell bist außer
jetzt die klimakleber die sind ja für
alle Terroristen
unglaublich so ich habe mal meiner
Frauen Streich gespielt und habe ihr
labellostift mit so ein patteckstift
ausgetauscht einfach die Banderole von
Labello drumum
gemacht war ruhig gewesen im Urlaub den
ganzen Tag
tschü
hi
so wo sollst denn hingehen in die
Berufsschule aber sag mal stehen sie
nicht eigentlich im
Halteverbot genau das meine ich genau
das meine ich wenn ich 5 Minuten mal im
Halteverbot stehe weil ich einmal nicht
in der Flasche pinken will da werde ich
behandelt wie so ein Schwerverbrecher
aber der Herr Lindner ja unser
Porschefahrer der stellt ein Haushalt
auf der nicht verfassungskonform ist und
was passiert niich sind wir in der
waldchule oder was keine Hausaufgaben
keine Konsequenzen ich persönlich hätte
den Lindner ja mit dem Taschenrechner
vor die Tür gestellt der soll mal
ausrechnen wie so ein privater Haushalt
mit Bürgergeld klarkmen soll das soll
mir mal sagen der Schnösel haben sie
sich mal heutzutage ein richtig g in
Hamburger gekauft dann müssten sie es
eigentlich nennen Nudel mit ketchupgeld
oder meinst du dazu bist du das quizaxi
quizaxi sag mal hast du nicht zugehört
oder was ich habe gerade gesagt nichts
passiert niente Nader der schön geföhnte
Lindner der sitzt da im Bundestag rum
als wäre nichts gewesen ja wenn ich ein
Strafzettel wenigstens mit Paypal
bezahlen
könnte Digitalisierung im Arsch ja da
muss ich schön rüber zur Vater dit da
sein Online Banking und aber ist eine
ganz andere Geschichte sag mal was ist
denn das hier das ist Jahresrückblick du
Pfeife ach so aber kannst du das es ein
bisschen leise machen ach weißt
du kannst mich mal K mich alle mal le
[Musik]
mich dabei hei sein Hein Hein dabei hei
sein Hein jer J und rückwärts Herz Herz
Herz Herz aber abonnieren hier sie den
heute heute show
Kanal ja ich habe lange auf der Kirmis
gearbeitet mehr dazu demnächst beim
heuteshow
Kanal